hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest chess event in online history
it's Magnus awesome versus Hikaru
Nakamura it's the first match we're
gonna cover part of the Magnus Carlsen
Invitational like I said the biggest
ever event online with a prize fund of
250,000 dollars and today we're gonna
see matches between Carlson and Nakamura
and also between ding Liron and ali reza
fuchsia and then to Matt two more
matches tomorrow which will also include
Yaya mushy Fabiana caruana onigiri and
maps impartial a graph so this is the
first game of their match already quite
an exciting one I don't know how many
I'm gonna show but I imagine I imagine I
will show all the decisive game so if
you start getting a lot of notifications
in the you know a couple of few day in
the next few days it's it's as it is but
okay now without further ado let's check
out the game Magnus with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have Knight to
f6 by Nakamura c4 e6 we have Knight to
f3 and d5 so just a normal Queens gambit
the client will Knight to c3 by magnets
and Bishop to e7 Bishop to f4 this is
what Magnus decided to use against
Nakamura Queens gambit declined
we have castles and III now so all
standard stuff preparing to develop the
lights were Bishop 9b d7 and now c5 in
the old days it was said that this is a
well a positional mistake as black will
be able to undermine undermine it later
would be six before in the a5 but
nowadays in modern chess it is very much
played and here you have to be careful
not to attack it right away because you
then allow white c6 and you will have
some problems developing for example
Bishop can defend it and if a6 Queen and
for prevents the captures and really
puts a lot of strain on blacks position
and black will have really a lot of
difficulties so instead of nakamora
blocks that with c6 first and only then
will he attack it with b6
we have h3 and of course b6 will be for
defending it in now a5 attacking the
base of the point
a three defending once again and now h6
by Nakamura we have Bishop to d3
continuing development and now a
Nakamura already had this position on
the board only he was white he had the
position against the pall of into
Poliquin for Bishop to a six here and
pretty much hold all the games that
reach this position and well Bishop to
e6 was played but here Bishop to be 7 by
Nakamura it is the the top engine
recommended move so Nakamura improved on
his game
well he didn't improve on his game
against the power he improved on top
always move against against him and it
is as a move 11 that we have a
completely new game so this is basically
where our game starts Magnus castles and
we have Queen to c8 now by Nakamura now
of preparing this Bishop the a6 move
here Magnus doesn't want to trade light
square bishop so he shifted the rook
over to e1 so after Nakamura attacks
it's a magnet just slides the bishop
over to see do you know avoiding the
trade we have looked at e8 and now rook
the c1 getting the rook on the same file
as the black Queen with eight capture
son before a captures and another trade
on c5 characteris captures and now
Bishop the d8 by Nakamura he wants to
play Bishop to c7 and trade his bishop
for cross and strong dark square bishop
so here across and says no more there's
no more reason for this rook to remain
on the C file so rook to a-1 and I will
bash up the c7 with the idea of trading
with Queen to d2 not worried about this
doubling of pawns because if characters
captures then white has a firm grip on
the e5 square when he lands that night
there it's gonna be it was just gonna be
a good position for white so ii v
instead my nakamura if you if white
allows it why not plate and here we go
into a into a capture fest we have
characters on e5 characters on e5 with
the night wheel Knight captures Bishop
captures and Bishop captures rook
captures and now after all has been
traded Magnus has to decide between
efore or queen today for he first the
centralizes the queen and after rook to
e8 only now pushes efore we have some
more trades characters characters we
have characters and bishop kappa sorry
not the bishop
rook actress offering yet another trade
and here we reach already a critical
position here Nakamura has to play
Bishop to b5 well there are other moves
you could play but Bishop to b5 is the
best
however it's not easy - not easy to
decipher why why it's the best way to go
instead Nakamura went to work the d8 he
attacked Carlson's Queen we have Queen
to c3 and now the point is you cannot go
Bishop to b5 now if you do it now then
capture scatters and rook the g4 will
create big problems for for black for
example if g5 if you defended Queen f6
now comes your threatening to capture
this Bishop to b3 is coming and it's
just gonna be an impossible position to
hold so Nakamura went to rook the d5
puts pressure on the pawn also now if
rook comes to g4 you can just block it
with rook to g5
but now Carlsen finds a very nice idea
he plays rook eat a4 and now you see why
Bishop to b5 was an important move now
the bishop is under pressure and white
will gladly attack it again for example
if Queen to a 3 then that Bishop really
comes under under siege so Bishop to b7
is forced but now comes rope captures
Bishop characters and now Queen to a5
now saying that this Bishop is now a
target Bishop to b7 is forced but the
pro real problem for nakamura is that
now he has this bishop which is pretty
much a pawn it's staring at the c6 pawn
and it's not gonna be a very useful
piece whereas Magnus has a beautiful
light square bishop so Queen to b6 now
preparing to bring the rook also into
the attack a weave g6 numbing the the
light square bishop here and first blush
of the e4
attacking the rook we have looked back
to d7 now adding the defender and the
bishop back to f3 and now cousin says
okay
the material is equal three points on
the King side one on the Queen side each
but my bishop is much superior and much
more superior than your bishop so what
are you gonna do here he car went h5 and
now rook to e1 shifting the rook over to
the e-file and now comes Queen to d8
here
carl offers a trade of queens as it's
very hard to improve the position with
that Bishop on b7 he's hoping to remove
some pieces of the board and then maybe
bringing it to the game with Bishop day
sex although it will be hard as this
Bishop constantly keeps an eye on the c6
pawn so Magnus gladly trade we have
clean captures rook captures and now
rook to e7 saying you either go back for
example - aah - keep an eye on the pawn
but then I'm just gonna shift my best
trip for example to c4 put pressure on
f7 you're gonna have to keep her kind of
faith and you're gonna have a rout kind
of fate and Bishop on e8 regarding the
c6 pawn pretty much black will not have
a move to play for the rest of the game
so instead and Nakamura decided to give
up the c6 pawn to try and gain some
activity with Bishop to a6 and now
Magnus finally wins the pawn so this is
a everything he's done so far that
shifting the rook over to a5 and making
the best of really useless now results
in him winning upon so Brooke the c8
hoping that the bishop moves and you
recaptured a pawn but now Ruki 8 check
we've captures Bishop characters and
King f8 bishop the c6 and h4 now with f4
by Magnus he's a puppy he's up upon but
he still has to prove that that it's
winning King is 7 we have team king - f2
both players start bringing their Kings
into the game F sex with King to e3 we
have King to e6 and now Bishop the e4
the the bishop and pawns very nicely
create a wall against the black king so
he cannot advance anywhere with g5 and
here Magnus just gives it up King to d4
improves the position of the King G
captures on f4 and now Bishop the d5
with checks saying that if you want to
infiltrate what King to 5 then c6 will
be very problematic I can just shift my
King either here or here and it's just
gonna be a very easy win for me
so instead Bishop d5 checking back to e7
and now King e4 now Magnus will reclaim
the pawn bishop to c8 and by Nakamura
and now King captures on f4 so not only
is he a papon but he also messed up I
can knock Morris pawn structure on the
inside Bishop to d7 and not g3 with with
this move finally creating another
Passport so you either capture at this
point or even or if you try Bishop
captures on h3 then G captures on h4 and
white already has a passed pawn on h4 so
it doesn't really make a difference so
we have characters here characters here
King to f8 and the not h4 again the pawn
finds its way to h4 King g7 and now
Quinta 4 and basically if you if you've
ever studied studied the endings when
you have two points against one in
impositions like like these basically
want to apply the principle of two
weaknesses making it impossible for
black to keep an eye on both of these
pawns so this is what Carson will now
attempt King h6 with Bishop back to f3
taking away all of these squares from
the black King not allowing him to
approach the H pawn King back to g7 we
have King be for now the King will try
and go up the board Bishop c6 check King
III of course black cannot trade as two
points against one always win most of
the times Bishop to b5 and now King D
for Magnus starts bringing the King into
the game King f7 and King to d5 now we
have Quinta e7 and now Bishop to g4 not
allowing King to cross the d7 square
also keeping an eye on this pawn so
Bishop to d3 Nakamura is ready to meet
c6 with f5 but this exactly what
Crossing goes for we have c6 f5
attacking the bishop on g4 but now
Bishop to f3 even though a c7 is just as
winning but it's it's a rapid game you
don't want to over calculate something
that's so Bishop to f3 and the bishop
back the b5 we have c7 by Magnus now
it's pretty much the same idea King to
d7 attacking the pawn and now came to e5
going after the f5 point we have f4
clearing this diagonal for the light
square bishop so you could maybe the
defend against the H pawn this way and
now h5 here Carson starts pushing the
pawn so Bishop to c4 if you go to d3
then this
can just block you with Bishop to e4 and
h6 now we have Bishop the g8 not
allowing the point across the h7 square
but now Bishop to d5 by Magnus saying
okay now if you capture I just push the
pawn and there's no stopping promotion
so Bishop to h7 and now comes the Bishop
to e4 Bishop back the g8 by Nakamura and
here
Magnus just played King characters on f4
and it was in this position unmoved 67
that he called Nakamura resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so what if you resign of course
again like I said we have the principle
of two weaknesses you have to take care
of one of them and now you will no
longer be able to attend to the other
one king e5 you're just gonna bring your
King a closer King f6 you're gonna go
King g8 in g7 and that's it one you
either when the bishop or the bishop
moves in on h7 wins as there's no
stopping promotion on h8 so yeah first
game between Carson and Nakamura from
the Magnus cross and Invitational goes
to Magnus Carlsen but it is quite the
match so we are going to definitely show
some more games stay tuned and I would
like to thank ice of Jacobson Mahesh
MODOK dog McNab Marvin bolt and crispy
card for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video Sarah thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely covering the Magnus cross
and Invitational until it ends unless we
get a lot of free temptin we're gonna
squeeze in a nice more fee game or
whatnot and also yes do support fish net
for leech chest I will put info on water
this in the description below so for
those of you who are interested in
helping helping them out so thank you
all I will see you soon in heaven extra
rest of your day